he's showing with this something which
was little good time last year into this
season he's a scorer also Miranda would
not be denied by Ricky Rubio got to the
top of ties the game at five two minutes
in tough break there for bridges here's
the drive and the finish Kyle Anderson
they call him slow-mo always one of
those players that he was this funny
time to grow into his body and when he
did and transferred over to the north
yeah Wow indeed
Moran against Javon Carter it's a Clark
screen drive scoops it stars John
[Applause]
still peeing yourself Maran down the
lane
change the dock into a lake
this on can hurt Eddie Johnson yeah the
night talking about then maybe having a
place Mike's moving
[Applause]
used to buy some senators Valentinus
machinery Brandon Clark
make people fill any other way with this
two hands finished here I'll be Paul PJ
Tucker and yes that is your starting
point guard for the Memphis Grizzlies
have it first two starts the second job
I ran for the life earlier would be see
here pass up top cut look and drew mow
able to finish up high he'll get have
these opportunities no bigs on the foot
the nice tip with a let though he's
going up with two can't do it look how
high he is it's those guys and Sharon
Jackson well it is because of those type
moves right Moran was 16 the only
grizzly and double figures also has five
assists Valanciunas go checked in his
mouth
crafty finisher with the left going up
against the bigger Clint capela calf up
scoring this season shooting 55% from
the floor is the are the right hand see
Kennedy can continue to fight see they
come more times than not that is a
dribble handoff to a high screen and
roll this time a rant to back it should
embrace something because of the plays
that he's able to make you see here
back-to-back loners
here's again that left hand the right
hand is able to seal keep the defender
away as he goes into the nice floater
able to muscle that one if it's one of
your old rookie that was a set play and
it's executed perfectly out of that
timeout the big reason of why they leave
the NBA scoring in that paint played
among two different players strange late
whistle but a correct whistle I like
what you see it oh my goodness
[Applause]
what did we do siege split my behind the
back and look away and split again and
then gets it up and around Cody Zeller I
mean that's in traffic this guy was in
the Ohio Valley Conference last year
both teams continued to shoot a good
ball a change of pace oh you got away
with oh that's just an in and out
dribble yeah absolutely
hit ball is handled under the ball
there's quarter third quarter Hornet
shot 55% the first quarter they shoot
54% the deal and they went both quarters
in this wild back door here
switches out of the race
[Applause]
rode the initiative man
[Applause]
that's out - Anderson here is moran
turning on the burgers ridiculous finish
from joe bereta and the back moves down
right oh just watch where he starts it
that starts at the free-throw line into
the [ __ ] of him as a shooter because
he's so efficient he said no no Jerry
this alley-oop is mine I ran into a
crowd no luck
he's good persist in the game and that
was a beauty James see a nice drop off
past there by Moran even better comes
along budget good hands by Ingalls but
Moran gets it back dances away from
because it looks like he's stripped and
he doesn't have a lot of space to get
between those guys put this hand down
big-time athlete very Harris you see
here is my rent takes off their yoke as
you can see the first time this year
that I think this team has been favorite
to win a basketball game
they found without mistake so the
mentality nice move all right
pretty one among on bottom fight Denver
this is an opportunity for Golden State
then a seven-game losing streak there
they're gonna play desperate ball too so
negate the shot blocking of this Lakers
team which is number one in the league
at almost any game by being able to get
out run had them out of position nice
finish here through contact by Marissa
art he's able to see this cross-court
here going to the right here's a yes on
the hill in the right corner but he
feels though let me get Jake proud of
the plan that has been knocking down
shots as of late let's keep him see here
Moran gets to the baseline missed a foul
that's easily a foul get hurt hurt
somebody
to the rim
[Applause]
a bigger body well Moran doesn't care he
take the ball to the bass imma show it
with the right hand
last time on the first win against
Brooklyn and that's around like a ghost
we moved there how can you respond
Grizzlies have been absorbing Nemo's
haymakers throughout the night delayed
deliver one of their own and there's no
ran off the key trainer Solomon Hill got
the blobs and junior jumper win he
turned the jump shot down and kept going
further to the basket here he comes up
with a steal nice job to reward the big
running the floor hard as Valanciunas
and the Grizzlies have gotten this fit
these fans on their feet because of
great deepest end moves like that where
we're able to clock down to six Moran
trying to shake free from Beverly Chuck
got down to three a deep three Moran
[Applause]
[Music]
my rant with the shot clock winding down
over Patrick Beverley one step in front
of the payer but you just keep the ball
in your hand and figure out can you
create something well something was
created there I set up there by John
Moran in tight house good pass to the
corners missus comfortable with that
left hand is job Moran
[Applause]
then I'll call it there with the
reaching in
[Applause]
so Utah's over the limit so there still
will be free-throws 24 Mitchell 27 foot
bucks out of it Valanciunas leads the
Grizzlies with 22 job
[Applause]
as high as 30 degree against Milwaukee
moretz down the lane and powers it in
Gobert did not challenge and it's a
three-point game